piers morgan loses his job for ripping
woke princess meghan markle
the media rushed to defend awful new
york times pseudo-reporter taylor lorenz
and disney ceo says the gina carano
firing wasn't political at all
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so the drama in the uk
continues oh my goodness wow well now
the drama has reached the point where
the royal family has responded to the
accusations
made by megan markel and prince harry in
this
bombshell interview with oprah winfrey
in which she asked precisely zero
difficult follow-up questions and
allowed them to just
essentially call the royal family a
bunch of racist
bigoted terrible people to the
celebration of the media
and again here's my view as an american
royal family don't care all that much
because here's the thing we fought a
revolution to stay away from the royals
but
but the reason that the media have
decided that the royal family is bad is
because the royal family is emblematic
of british history the royal family is
emblematic of british institutions and
therefore the royal family has to be
torn down and if you need a woke
second-rate american actress to do it
well then that's what's handy so just go
for it and anybody who stands in their
way will be torn down
as well so the royal family has now
issued a statement and it's hilarious
because people on the left
are pretending that this sort of hostage
statement from the royal family
represents them admitting the truth of
what meghan markle had to say about them
being racists and
and then suggesting bad things about her
baby or stripping her baby of of his
title even though by the way the baby
had no legal title under british law
since 1917
because that baby is not in line for the
crown in any case
according to the hill buckingham palace
is responding to prince harry and megan
the duchess of sussex bombshell
interview
with oprah winfrey saying the royal
family is quote-unquote saddened by the
challenges the couple faced especially
those regarding race because this is the
way
that you're supposed to deal this is
what the the pr experts tell you you're
supposed to do
when you face an accusation you're not
just allowed to say i don't think the
accusation is true
you're not allowed to say that anymore
right even if you're andrew cuomo and
you believe that all the women who are
now coming out of the woodwork
are not telling the truth about things
you're not just allowed to say i don't
think that's true
you have to say instead we are so happy
that they are telling their story and
they are entitled to their opinion about
all of this so that is what the royal
family is now doing with meghan markle
right they put out a statement it says
the whole family is saddened to learn
the full extent of how challenging the
last few years have been
for harry and megan which is not an
admission of guilt by the way the issues
raised particularly that of race are
concerning again
not an admission of guilt or that any of
the stuff that meghan markle said
happened with regard to her
going to the palace and saying that she
was suicidal and then ignoring her and
basically
saying well whatever lady or them being
completely racist and trying to deprive
her children
of benefits right they're not admitting
to any of that they're just
using the mushmouth kind of corporate
speak that allows you to evade
responsibility while simultaneously
patting the woke on the head
right that is i'm very sorry you felt
this way i'm sorry you felt this way is
what the royal family is now saying
the statement from buckingham palace
left room to dispute some of the
couple's accusations they said
well some recollections may vary they
are taken very seriously and will be
addressed by the family privately
while some recollections may vary is
code for we don't think that what she's
saying is true
right that that is what that is code for
okay if somebody comes to you
and they make an accusation and you say
well you know my recollection varies
what you are saying is that you don't
think that's true that is what the royal
family is saying
they're not admitting guilt now i
understand that the way our media work
is that we are supposed to pretend that
none of this
matters right we're supposed to pretend
that because meghan markle made an
accusation and because
meghan markle is a woke person and she's
released video after video over the
course of the last year calling america
systemically racist
and suggesting that all of western
society is systemically racist and all
this because meghan markle checks all
the proper woke boxes this means we must
believe her right listen and believe
and apparently not only is this mandated
by our woke media
it is also mandated apparently by
british law in some way
so our woke media were totally on board
with this don lemon on cnn over the
course of the last couple of days
he actually said we don't even need to
hear from the other side
right meghan markle is so eminent
eminently believable and she is so
victimized within the system that we can
believe what she says because it rings
true
now i have to say we have watered down
victimhood pretty far
when you are talking about a woman who
is a b-rate actress on a second-rate usa
network show
becoming a princess of the uk
and then leaving in order to get a giant
netflix deal and living on a 14.5
million estate in california on her
mother-in-law's 25 million dollar
endowment that that seems not super
victory
especially when you're not providing any
sort of extraneous evidence of the
accusations that you're making but
according to don lemon
if it's good enough for for meghan
markle it's good enough for don lemon
and being a great journalist don lemon
says listen
this checks all of my priors since my
priors are that america's racist the
royal family is racist
western history is racist this means
that meghan markle has to be telling the
truth i don't even have to check the
story the story is too good to check
here is don lemon objective journalist
journalism all over the place hot sticky
journalism getting just all over the cnn
studios here
when people say well we haven't heard
from the other side what's the other
side going to say
they're going to say of course we're not
racist or whatever but what did they do
think about their actions
they they did not stand up for their own
because their own was married to a black
woman had a black child
they didn't listen to him inside of the
royal family they let him go they let
him leave the country they wouldn't come
to terms with
what they wanted to do so listen we've
only heard from one side but that one
side at this point
rings very true okay the ring is true
therefore i won't check the other side
that's great journalism guys amazing
journalism there from
don lemon so that is the way that most
of the establishment media has treated
the accusations by meghan markle now
here's the thing the british public
disagrees according to the uk sun there
was a poll it said that 51
of brits want them stripped of any royal
title only 28
want them to remain official members of
the royal family after that particular
interview okay so over
on uk tv over on itv which is a big
channel over in the uk
piers morgan was on good morning britain
again piers morgan is a big critic of
meghan markle he has been for quite a
while
he was kind of friendly with meghan
markle for a while apparently and then
she
apparently ghosted him after she got
involved with prince harry
and she was kind of nasty to him and
this is you know according to according
to piers
and then he didn't like the way that she
was treating the royal family apparently
she was trying to throw her weight
around inside the royal family she
didn't respect a lot of the traditions
and so morgan's been a long time critic
of
of meghan markle now full disclosure i'm
friendly with piers now
i mean that is the hilarious of our the
hilarious hilarity of our current
political moment
is that anyone who doesn't buy into
every narrative of the woke
is now on one side and the walker on the
other that is the way this works so
anyway
piers morgan was very critical of meghan
markle
on the show he said i don't believe a
word that comes out of her mouth right
the direct quote
from piers morgan is he said that if she
i wouldn't believe it if she read me a
weather report he was talking about her
report that not only was she suicidal
but that she went to members of the
palace
and that they basically dismissed her
complaints about being suicidal he said
who did you go to what did they say to
you i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
said meghan markle i wouldn't believe it
if she read me a weather report
okay now this resulted in a massive
outpouring of criticism because how dare
piers morgan say that in his opinion he
doesn't believe
meghan markle you must believe right as
don lemon says
she fits all the categories so you must
believe you don't even have to check the
story you don't have to find out the
other side
okay so this resulted yesterday in piers
morgan on good morning britain
getting into a spat with this guy who is
apparently like the weather guy
on good morning britain on itv who
basically
said that morgan's take on the situation
was disgusting and piers got mad and
walked off the show
i understand that you've got a personal
relationship
with mega market or had one and she cut
you off
she's entitled to cut you off if she
wants to
has she said anything about you since
she cut you off i don't think she has
but yet you continue
the brits so he goes after morgan morgan
walks off the show
and now morgan's out of a job now the
reason that morgan is out of job is not
because he walked off the show
the reason that morgan is out of a job
is because the government started to
investigate itv
and you know who's a person who put in a
complaint to itv
our great victim the victim of the hour
meghan markle
because nothing says victimhood quite
like trying to exercise institutional
power in order to get somebody fired
that is definitely
a good thing to do okay we're gonna get
to more of this in just one second first
you know i was up at 5 30 this morning
because my kids have decided that they
are are now going to collude in
preventing me from sleeping now each day
it is a different kid
they have a rotating schedule of torture
this morning it was my
baby the squishy baby she woke me up at
5 30 this morning that meant i had to go
heavy
on the black rifle coffee you got to
kick-start your day and chase your goals
with the most delicious most liberating
coffee known to man i'm talking about
black rifle coffee black rifle coffee
company is a veteran-owned coffee
company
serving premium coffee to people who
love america veterans ceo and founder
evan hafer spent over seven years on the
ground overseas with u.s special forces
and as a cia contractor i haven't even
modified his gun trucks during the
invasion of iraq to grind coffee
anywhere i know evan good dude brcc is
continually committed to supporting
veteran
law enforcement and first responder
causes when the companies buy a bad give
a bag campaign they make sure to give
the gift of america's coffee to those
that serve around the globe
in 2020 they donated over six million
cups of coffee they've got all sorts of
great roasts
i love i love my black rifle coffee in
the morning love the smell of black
rifle coffee in the morning go to
blackrafflecoffee.com
shapiro to get 20 percent off your
purchase and your first coffee club
order
it is the unwoke coffee company that is
blackriflecoffee.comblackrifle
the best way to enjoy that brcc coffee
is through the coffee club that's a free
subscription your chosen coffee is
roasted packaged shipped free to your
door on your schedule
in addition to convenience you get
special discounted pricing you gain
access to exclusive products member-only
content partner discounts and more
go check them out blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro to get started okay so
apparently according to the hollywood
reporter meghan markle filed an itv
complaint against piers morgan which is
not
babyish behavior at all somebody
criticizes you on tvs you file a
complaint with their bosses
i'm sorry that's childish behavior under
any circumstances
i've received more than my share of
criticism over the course of my career
i'm a public figure that's the way that
it works i cannot remember
filing a complaint with somebody's boss
asking to have them disciplined for
something they said about me
in fact i have a number of fairly good
friends
whose friendships were initiated by them
writing something crappy about me in a
fairly prominent place me reaching out
and saying i appreciated them listening
to the stuff even though i think they
got it wrong
but not meghan markle apparently
according to the hollywood reporter
neither itv nor archwell have denied
that a complaint was lodged on behalf of
the duchess
meghan markle made a formal complaint to
itv following piers morgan's incendiary
comments about the duchess the uk
broadsheet newspapers have reported both
the guardian and the telegraph claim
a complaint was lodged on behalf of the
royal after monday's episode of good
morning britain in which morgan
repeatedly lashed out at prince harry
and markle over their revelations
in the explosive interview with oprah
winfrey the growing fuhrer over the
former cnn hosts tirade one that also
saw him storm offset after being rebuked
on air by a colleague would ultimately
lead to him quitting the breakfast news
show with itv making the announcement he
was standing down on tuesday evening
among morgan's most controversial
comments was that he didn't believe
markle's claims she had felt suicidal
and had reached out for support from
buckingham palace
only for it to be rejected okay so he
didn't actually say i don't believe that
she felt to his title right he didn't
actually say that if you go back and
watch the comments what he said is i
don't believe a word she says which is a
pretty blanket statement and what he
specifically cited was he didn't believe
that she had gone to the palace and the
palace had been like
yeah you're suicidal well you know if
something bad happens that's kind of on
you
it's gonna look bad for the family if we
bring in a psychiatric they have their
own medical team
inside buckingham palace okay the
comments drew
widespread condemnation including from a
mental health charity and led to more
than 41 000 complaints
to regulator ofcom okay and this is
where this becomes relevant for
americans
okay because we are now living in a
world in the united states
where many many people in america want
an american version of ofcom
so what exactly is ofcom so ofcom
is a regulatory agency who
sees its job as to regulate the way that
media is done
okay ofcom is a uh is again
a government agency that is designed to
regulate what people can and cannot say
in december of 2020 the regulator
launched a review of what protections
were in place
with regard to mental health and
well-beings of individuals who take part
in their show the commons digital
culture media and sports select
committee
has launched inquiries into the reality
tv industry for example
ofcom creates measures aimed at
protecting vulnerable people and others
not being used to not used to being in
the public eye
ofcom has its own director of standards
and audience protection
okay and so ofcom which is this again
this british agency which regulates it's
sort of like the fcc except it has an
enormous power of of
over over actual broadcast in a way that
the fcc really does not
ofcom is the office of communications
it's the government-approved regulatory
and competition authority for
broadcasting telecommunications
and again they have wide ability to
punish people for saying things
they don't like so apparently there was
an official investigation
by ofcom by the uk media regulator based
on piers morgan saying he didn't believe
meghan markle
which is nuts okay that's an opinion by
piers morgan
how do you get investigated for an
opinion i'm confused
see here in america we have this thing
called freedom of speech and the first
amendment is pretty great
in britain they don't have the same
thing european standards of speech are
very different this is why they've hate
speech regulations
they they seek to measure harm of speech
against value of speech which of course
is a completely subjective decision
there's no limiting principle to it and
so ofcom does this on a regular basis
according to variety ofcom launched an
investigation after more than 41 000
people wrote in to complain about itv's
good morning britain host piers morgan's
comments on meghan markle so first of
all
who gives a crap right in the united
states if a bunch of people wrote in
to the fcc about me having an opinion
about meghan markle
you know what the result will be nothing
because we have a first amendment in
this country thank god
they don't have the same thing in
britain on monday's edition of the show
of course
morgan made his comments and so now
ofcom was apparently investigating an
afghan spokesperson told variety
we have quote launched an investigation
into monday's episode under good morning
britain
under our harm and offense rules harm
and offense rules
okay like the fact that you have harm
in a supposedly free country means that
your country is not nearly as free as
you are pretending that it is
now morgan did come back on the air on
tuesday before the walk-off
and he said when we talked about this
yesterday i said as an all-encompassing
thing i don't believe what meghan markle
is saying generally in this interview
and i still have serious concerns about
the veracity of a lot of what she said
but let me just state for the record on
my position on mental illness and on
suicide these are clearly extremely
serious things and should be taken
extremely seriously and if someone is
feeling that way they should get the
treatment and help they need every time
and if they belong to an institution
like the royal family and they go and
seek that help they should absolutely be
given it
it's not for me to question if she felt
suicidal i'm not in her mind and that is
for her to say
my real concern was a disbelief that she
went to a senior member of the royal
household and told them she was suicidal
and was told she couldn't have any help
because it would be a bad look for the
family
if that's true first that person should
be fired and second the royal family had
serious
questions that need to be answered but
that apparently didn't fix the problem
right morgan still had to go because
morgan had offended
the woke princess and the woke princess
the powerless victimized woke princess
and her fans got him fired and got an
investigation going
from the office of communications in the
uk
okay it's usually pretty easy to tell
who is a victim and who's the victimizer
in a situation
like this the way that you can tell is
who is the person who is threatening to
actually do something to another person
that's how you can tell who the actual
victim is here and meghan markle
was not threatened by piers morgan in
any way he had an opinion
his opinion said that he didn't believe
a lot of what made meghan markle to say
and
i frankly agree with a lot of that i
don't agree with a lot of i don't
believe some of
what meghan markle had to say either i
find it largely self-serving
but the fact is that that in our culture
if you claim victimhood this apparently
gives you ultimate power to actually
harm other people see here's the thing
we now live in a society where if piers
morgan says something that offends
meghan markle that is considered harm if
meghan markle files a complaint with itv
with the intent of getting piers morgan
fired
that is not an actual harm so one loses
their job
the other has their feelings a little
bit hurt and one is considered a very
very serious harm now how do we
determine what the harm is
we simply look to intersectionality we
determine who's more woke if you're woke
you're a victim
even if you're the victimizer you're the
victim that's the way this works now the
woke are the actual royalty the
woke are the actual american and
apparently british royalty
because now you have to be treated the
way that royalty ought to be treated no
one can say a word against you
and if a word is set against you you
will be investigated maybe you will be
fired
piers morgan did put out a statement
he uh on twitter he said on monday i
said i didn't believe meghan markle in
her oprah interview
i've had time to reflect on this opinion
and i still don't if you did okay
freedom of speech is a hill i'm happy to
die on thanks for all of the love and
the hate i'm off to spend more time
with my opinions and then he quoted
winston churchill some people's idea of
free speech that they are free to say
what they like but if anyone says
anything back
that is an outrage he later doubled down
he said i don't believe anything that
comes out of her mouth i think the
damage he's done to the british monarchy
into the queen at a time when prince
philip is lying in the hospital is
enormous
and frankly contemptible if i have to
follow my sword for expressing an
honestly held opinion about meghan
markle and that diatribe of bilge that
she came out with in that interview so
be it
i think it's fair to say although the
woke crowd will think they've canceled
me i think they'll be rather
disappointed
when i re-emerge okay we'll get to more
of this in just one second because of
course the woke
royalty doesn't actually have to be
royalty things just be members of our
establishment media we'll get to that in
just one second first
a lot is happening at your front door
these days you have a lot of packages
that are being delivered maybe you have
doordash delivering
your meal and you got a lot going on at
that front door you got to know who's at
the front door at all times
and if you're like me and you got a
bunch of kids that means you got to keep
an eye on the kids at all time
but here's the thing i have three kids i
only have two eyes and they move in the
same direction generally and so that
means it's difficult to keep an eye on
all of them this is why i love ring ring
helps me do all of these things i can
keep an eye on my home i can keep an eye
on that front door
with my ring devices now is the perfect
time to upgrade your doorstep with a
ring video doorbell with ring
you can see and speak to whomever is at
your door from anywhere right on your
phone so you're never gonna miss a
visitor whether it's your neighbor
dinner or groceries you can keep those
packages and delivery safe with motion
detection you'll get notified even if
they don't ring the doorbell
if someone stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know i love
having the ring video doorbell
i've actually added ring security
cameras around the house as well
again ring is going to make your life
better and safer and you're going to be
more in control of your own home
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ring.com ben it comes with that
ring video doorbell 3 and the chime pro
it's the perfect way to upgrade your
front door
and start your ring experience go to
ring.com
once more that is ring.com go check them
out right now
ring.com ben okay so the woke
being the actual western royalty at this
point
you can't say a word against the woke
because if you disagree with the woke
this proves that you are unwoke and
therefore unfit for public consumption
piers morgan losing his job over saying
that he disagrees with meghan markle and
doesn't believe her
that is not an actual harm piers morgan
having said he doesn't believe her is
the actual harm because of course she is
not just a princess she's a woke
princess
okay well we have our own version of the
woke
royal cased or cast here in the united
states as well they're members of our
media
taylor lorenz is a pseudo reporter over
the new york times when i say pseudo
reporter i mean the taylor
lorenz basically spends her days just
trolling
the internet for bad things that people
have said and then trying to get them
canceled
that is her main job most recently she
went on clubhouse and she tried to get
a tech investor cancelled for not saying
a thing he didn't say something she
accused him of saying it he was marc
andreessen
and so she is um i would say a bad
reporter
she's not a reporter at all she's an
activist just like many members of the
new york times
woke editorial crew well yesterday she
put out a tweet
and here's her tweet for international
women's day please consider supporting
women enduring online harassment
it's not an exaggeration to say that the
harassment and smear campaign i've had
to endure over the past year has
destroyed
my life no one should have to go through
this so number one don't harass people
online
number two if your way of commemorating
international women's day
is to say and also could you guys please
be nice to me
that's rather self-centered but taylor
lorenz of course checks the woke boxes
right she mirrors woke politics
she is woke herself and so this means
that the entire media infrastructure
rushed to her defense for this rather
self-centered tweet
so tucker carlson points out that taylor
loren's claiming that she's a victim
when she spends most of her day trying
to find people to get them fired
and to ruin their careers is rather
ironic so tucker went after her on fox
news last night
by most people's standards taylor lorenz
would seem to have a pretty good life
one of the best lives in the country in
fact
lots of people are suffering right now
but no one's suffering quite as much as
taylor lorenz is suffering
people have criticized her opinions on
the internet and it destroyed her life
let's pause on this international
women's day and recognize
that you thought female uyghurs had it
bad you haven't talked to taylor lorenz
okay so the media went into full defense
mode for taylor lorenz of course
so you had a member of the washington
post
the media reporter for the washington
post person named jeremy barr
tweeting out notice how many times
tucker carlson says taylor's full name
on this highly watched television show
that's not
a coincidence he said her name
so first of all i thought we're supposed
to say people's names generally now but
but apparently not apparently we're not
supposed to say people's names
because if you say their names many
times then this is a form of targeting
which is a weird take but the
notification went out on the woke slack
channels
and so this became the talking point
among the among the media left
a reporter from recode named teddy
schlieffer tweeted out this is so
dangerous and tucker carlson knows
exactly what he is doing so taylor
lorenzo again has spent her career
going after people and attempting to
destroy their careers if you mention her
name on fox
news this is a form of targeting now
steve peoples who is a reporter
for the ap tweeted out this is dangerous
and disgusting
someone asked for help after suffering
online harassment and this man mocks her
in prime time
using her full name five separate times
in an obvious attempt to encourage more
harassment
we are better than this okay i hope that
we are better than this crowd
is is ready to rush to the defense of
people who actually lose their jobs and
have their careers destroyed because
people like taylor lorenz are reporting
on their bad old tweets
i i somehow doubt it i somehow doubt it
the the woke brigade are as i say when i
say they're royalty i mean that they are
uncriticizable you're not supposed to
criticize them
you're not supposed to ask questions
about them and they have the power to
destroy
they have the the same sort of societal
ability
to excise people and ruin their lives as
the royalty
of old and they are the new royalty
and if you cross them at all they will
just come after you then they'll deny
they've done that of course but this is
this is the way our society currently
works we'll get to more of this in just
one second first you never thought covet
could cost you your home right
well it could now because cyber crime is
up 75 by far the most serious cyber
crime to worry about is home title theft
that is correct cyber criminals foreign
and domestic they're now after our homes
it's easier than you'd think the title
document to our home
it's online now the thief finds your
home's title forges your signature on a
quick claim deed stating you sold
your home to him and then he takes out
loans on your home and leaves you in
debt
you're not gonna know until too late
until you get those payments or eviction
notices
insurance won't cover you common
identity theft programs don't cover you
either the instant
home title lock detects someone
tampering with your home title they help
shut it down cold go to home
title lock dot com right now register
your address to see if you're already a
victim
and then use code radio to receive 30
free days of protection that is code
radio
at home title lock dot com and that's
home title lock.com you protect all your
other assets right you protect your data
online you make sure that you're
protecting your jewelry at home
you've got a safe well why exactly would
you leave your most valuable asset
namely your home title
out there for anybody to access instead
get home title lock protect your most
valuable asset
your home title and the value inheritant
go to home title lock.com register your
address and use code radio to receive
30 free days of protection okay so
how far has the woke brigade gone the
royalty well
they are ascendant in every area of
american life they're ascendant
everywhere
so for example winston marshall who is
from a band called mumford and sons he's
the banjo player
on mumford and sons apparently i'm not
aware of the band but all right
he put out a tweet a few days ago and
you can see this one coming a mile away
he put out a tweet a few days ago
recommending andy knows his new book
about antifa
this is bad this is cancelable
he read a book oh man wait till they
find out that winston marshall once read
if i ran the zoo i mean my goodness if
they find that out he's totally toast so
he then put out an abject apology for
having tweeted out a book
because if you tweet out a book that
some people don't like this means that
you actually have to have your career
destroyed or go into full penance mode
so winston marshall put out a tweet it
said over the past few days i have come
to better understand the pain
caused by the book i endorsed again this
is the way this this crap works
you trying to ruin his career isn't an
actual harm
him saying that he read a book
is an actual harm we now are in a place
where in order to designate something as
harmful no actual harm
must be done no actual harm must be done
in tort law if if you hit my car i can
sue you because you did a damage to me
if however we narrowly avoid a scrape i
cannot sue you
because you have not done any harm to me
however in american politics
harm is constituted if i say something
that offends you in any way
that is harm if you try to ruin my
career for having said something that
offends you in any way no matter how
innocuous like hey i read a book
then that is not a harm that is you just
zealously guarding decency
that's the way all this crap works right
now the only way the the deep
philosophical roots of that by the way
again go back to the notion that i've
now mentioned several times in the past
few weeks the notion that we define
ourselves through expressive
individualism right we want to express
ourselves
who we are is not how we interact with
reality realities of no consequence
we get to choose who we want to be every
single debate
every single day we get to define who we
are every single day and if you
challenge our self-definition
in any way and advertently or
inadvertently
then this means that you have somehow
done us a harm
right if you have if you refuse to
acknowledge my self-definition
this is an actual harm and i get to do
whatever i want to you
so if winston marshall read a book
saying antifa is bad
by andy no then this means that you can
go after his career
and you are good you are righteous for
doing so because he has done an actual
harm
the way by the way that you can tell who
the actual harm doer is so
in real life the way that you can tell
who's doing the harm is who actually did
serious damage to somebody that's how
you can tell who did the harm
that is in real life in woke land which
is now becoming real life
the way you can tell somebody has been
harmed is by are they a member of a woke
identity group if they're a member of a
woke identity group they don't actually
have to demonstrate harm was done to
them
all they have to demonstrate is that
they were offended by something and you
have challenged their self-identity
that is all they have to do it's a
hierarchy of power designed specifically
to exclude certain people
and to include certain people and to
obviate the need to demonstrate harm so
winston marshall didn't do any harm to
anybody he recommended a book you don't
like the book don't buy the book
that's fine but now he has to put out
this mulling apology he says over the
past few days i've come to better
understand the pain caused by the book i
endorsed by the way it didn't cause any
pain
i have offended not only a lot of people
i don't know but also those closest to
me
including my bandmates and for that i am
truly sorry because that means
his jackass band mates one time they're
like bro
i don't like how you uh it's like
beethoven i don't know
that was mean bro you know that that
book that's offensive bro
as a result of my actions i am taking
time away from the band to examine my
blind spots oh we're going to go to woke
reeducation camp
sounds great by the way he ain't coming
back to the band
and if he does anytime he says anything
else in the future they're just going to
slap him back into place
you know that's the way this works for
now please know i realize how my
endorsements have the potential to be
viewed as approvals
of hateful divisive behavior the entire
book that andy wrote is about how antifa
is hateful and divisive
but if you read the book and if you
recommend the book this means you've
done something hateful and divisive
because you have offended the woke
i apologize as this was not at all my
intention ah but intention doesn't
matter
again harm doesn't matter intention
doesn't matter all that matters is
whether somebody's
sense of identification has been
challenged in some way
it doesn't matter if you did it by
accident none of that matters it doesn't
matter if any actual harm was done
none of that matters because absolute
royalty comes with absolute privileges
and the absolute royalty of our society
now dictate the terms
which means that perfectly normal things
have to be gotten rid of
and when i say perfectly normal things i
mean like the word normal
so dove soap has now announced they will
no longer use the word normal on their
beauty program
on their beauty products so a lot of
people use
dove body wash for example all right we
use dub body wash in our home
and they have a bunch of different
brands of that body wash they have like
for sensitive skin
and they have for rough skin and then
they have for normal skin right meaning
not any of those things they've now
gotten rid of the word normal
because it might make some people feel
as though they are abnormal and if you
are abnormal
this means that you are bad and so you
feel bad about yourself now if you are
the kind of person who is walking
through the soap aisle at cvs
and you come across a dove product and
says the word normal and you start
crying in the aisle
i have a feeling your problem ain't of
soap okay you need some mental help
if you are so offended by the packaging
on a dove soap product
that dove has to change the name of the
product to acquiesce to your stupid
desires
the problem is you the problem is not
the word normal you are
dare i say it abnormal if you start
crying at a dove soap branding
decision this is because you are
abnormal you have an abnormality that is
not a normal thing to do
i am using the term normal in both the
generic and the statistical sense
statistical normality suggests the vast
majority of people do not cry at the
packaging on dove so packaging
at the words on dove so packaging the
sort of generic sense of normalcy is
that it is not a normal
regular or reasonable thing to do to be
very upset by the word normal
on dove soap but dove is now acquiescing
because dove has to be sensitive
it has to be very sensitive to those
with sensitive skin and not sensitive
skin
according to the new york times the
beauty and personal care company
unilever said on tuesday it would no
longer use the word normal on its
products
after a study revealed it makes most
people feel excluded
okay no most people don't feel excluded
most people don't give a crap
most people have never thought about
this it's just that when you ask people
if they're victims people know the math
they know how this works would you
rather be a member of the victimized
royalty or would you rather be one of
those
one of those people on the outside
looking in so yes i too feel very
offended by things
and that that sense of offense gives me
ultimate power
over the direction of society unilever
is a company based in london they own
dove
axe sun silk and vaseline among other
personal care brands they said they
would not digitally alter the body shape
size or skin color of models in its
advertising as part of the positive
beauty initiative
according to a news release because
obviously if you uh if you
don't if you just leave women looking
the way that they are
then that is somehow better than
digitally altering the women
for some reason that remains unspecified
an aim of these steps and others
unilever said was to better quote
challenge
narrow beauty ideals yes i'm sure that
men will find completely different
things hot
now that you're no longer digitally
photoshopping your models
now that you just left the pimple on the
face i'm sure that meant that you
you're right you've totally changed
society's standards of beauties
standards of beauty
now people will find completely
i'm sure that that your new models will
be you know people who are objectively
worse looking
that's probably what and you're going to
change society standards of beauty along
those lines
probably that's what's going to happen
the advertising changes came after the
company commissioned a 10 000 person
study across nine countries including
brazil china nigeria saudi arabia and
the us
the study found 56 percent of
participants thought the beauty industry
could make people feel excluded
could not does could okay which is not a
real study
oh my gosh could it make somebody feel
anything could make somebody feel
excluded
anything literally all the things could
make somebody feel excluded
seven in 10 people agreed the word
normal on products and in advertising
had negative effects eight in 10 people
agreed among participants aged 18 to 35
because again
anything that threatens your sense of
self-identity is bad and if you say that
something is normal and i happen not to
check that box
instead of me just saying okay well i
guess i'm not normal on that front
whatever
or maybe i'm not normal because i should
reconsider my behavior
instead it's the word normality itself
is the offense 74 of participants
said they wanted the beauty industry to
make them feel better not just look
better
there it is society is now responsible
for how you feel
which by the way is is number one it is
the recipe for a failed society also for
failed relationships by the way
if you expect your partner in a
relationship to quote-unquote make you
feel better that is a recipe for a
failed relationship you know who's
responsible for your feelings
you all you can say is that you wish
that your partner in a relationship
that their behavior were better but if
you are making someone else responsible
for your feelings you are going to have
a miserable life and if you as a society
are saying that society is responsible
for your feelings
you are destined to have a miserable
society that is the natural outcome
of all of this the woke are in control
of all the levers of power meanwhile
claiming victimization
it's an amazing amazing thing we're
going to get some more of this in just
one second
first let us talk about making your
company a more efficient place
finding great candidates to hire it can
be difficult it's like finding a needle
in a haystack often
sure you can post your job to some job
board but then all you can do is hope
the right person comes along that's why
you should try ziprecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire
ziprecruiter does the work
for you when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with one click and then
zip recruiter's matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply you
get qualified candidates fast
so while other services may overwhelm
you with applications to sift through
ziprecruiter finds you what you are
looking for the needle in the haystack
in fact
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter got a quality candidate
through the site within
the very first day right now you can
write zip recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire that is
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just head on over to
dailywire right now to check it out make
sure that your company is running on all
cylinders you've got to have the best
employees
zip crew will help you do it
ziprecruiter.com dailywire go check them
out right now you can try them
for free zip recruiters.com dailywire
alrighty well
before we get to more last november we
announced the one and only candace owns
would be joining the daily wire family
with a brand new show well
folks the long wait is now over
yes i'm thrilled to announce the daily
wire's newest show
kansas will be premiering next friday
march 19th
no one triggers the left quite like
candace whether she's slamming harry
styles for wearing a dress or
getting into a twitter war with cardi b
many have tried to cancel candace
all have failed it's it's hard not to
know about candace
if you are on the right and canada's
obviously one of the most popular
figures on the right for a while
now jumping in where angels fear to
tread in 2018 candace kicked off the
blexit foundation which aims to change
the narrative that surrounds america's
minority communities
she's also the author of the new york
times bestseller blackout how black
america can make its second escape from
the democrat
plantation get to know candace you know
the real candace every single week if
she shares her humor her insight as she
defies all the stereotypes starting next
friday march 19th
candace will be exclusive to daily wire
members if you aren't a member yet
go to dailywire.com subscribe use code
kansas for 25
off that is dailywire.com subscribe use
code candace for 25
off dailywire.com subscribe use code
candace get 25 percent off today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so again the the left is on the
march
you're not supposed to notice this by
the way right if you notice this it's
very bad
you're supposed to instead focus on the
spending bills and you're supposed to
focus
on the politics of the day now the
reality is you can focus on both right
you can focus on the politics of the day
and the spending bills you can also
focus focus on the whole culture but
when it comes to what impacts your daily
life most it is not in fact the spending
bills
coming out of congress it is in fact the
world culture that has invaded your
business i get i will tell you dozens of
emails every single day from people at
various major companies
around the united states and abroad
talking about the woke standards being
shoved
down their throats what they are forced
to say what they are forced to sit
through what they are forced to endure
and if they do not go along with it
whether they are fired or not and that
that happens
on a relatively frequent basis but then
we're told by these woke higher ups that
you know what when they do this kind of
stuff when they fire people for their
beliefs it's because they have universal
standards
the beauty of being a member of the the
woke royalty is that you can pretend
that your standard is everybody's
standard
this is what the ceo of walt disney
company bob chapic said on tuesday he
addressed the firing of gina carano from
the disney plus show the mandalorian
according to the hollywood reporter
the executive was asked about the
situation during an annual shareholders
meeting asked by a caller during the q a
portion if disney had a blacklist
insinuating corona by name was targeted
for conservative politics chapeck
responded he does not see disney as a
left-leaning or right-leaning company
okay literally yesterday disney plus
announced that they would not
allow the movies dumbo peter pan and the
aristocats
to be on children's playlists they had
to at least be seven or older
to access those those movies
why because presumably your
four-year-old is going to watch dumbo
and come away with racist understanding
of black americans
which is nuts okay first of all is there
some racist stuff
in dumbo if you understand the
references yes but if you're four do you
understand the references
no because you're four okay you actually
have to be in
you know how long it takes people to
this is the same thing
as philip bum from the washington post
saying i grew up on if i ran the zoo and
never thought there was anything racist
in it now i read it and there's
something racist
okay well then it didn't bother you at
the time and it didn't make you more
racist did it how many kids have been
made racist by dumbo
show of hands anybody bueller bueller
how many kids grew up thinking that
native americans are bad because they
watch peter pan
anybody anybody at all no
because again you don't have to show
actual harm all you have to show is
quote unquote potential for harm
all you have to do is say i am offended
by the way not by something even
directed at me
because usually it's woke white people
who are doing the work here usually it's
woke white people who are like yeah
dumbo's racist
how many black americans deeply care
about dumbo my guess is a very minimal
number
you know many white college graduates
care deeply about dumbo
probably a lot there's a vast gap
between
what woke white liberals think about the
world and what the people they are
supposedly defending think about the
world
for the same reason that woke white
liberals used the term latinx which no
latino person has ever used or will ever
use because it's idiocy
there are many many latino people who
work in this particular office
we have several producers and security
people and executive
executives of the company we have many
people working at this company or latino
not a single one of them
uses the term of tanks because it's an
idiotic term
and yet the walkway liberals will use it
it's huge for them
very important okay so when disney does
this sort of stuff and they say they're
not right leading or left-leaning wheel
no that's crap of course disney is
left-leaning
they're left-leaning because that's the
expectation of them
says disney stands for quote values that
are universal values of respect values
of decency values of integrity and
values of inclusion
oh so that's why you fired gina carano
for tweeting a thing that is
significantly less offensive
than anything that pedro pascal has
tweeted about immigration in the past
few years
literally comparing immigration america
to nazi death camps
is what pedro pascal did that's fine
gino carano however she had to go
says chapek we seek to have the content
that we make reflective of the rich
diversity of the world we live in
and i think that's a world we should all
live in harmony and peace
but don't worry he's not left wing he's
just going to spout a bunch of left-wing
bull crap at you
i'm not left-wing i'm just going to say
the words harmony and peace and
diversity over and over again but that's
not left-wing at all
now those are universal values that are
only held by people i agree with
who are left-wing but i'm not left-wing
it's just absurdity on its face
obviously
and unfortunately it's this sort of
absurd this is one of the things that
has happened on college campuses
one of the one of the great sort of
one of the great sort of mental moves on
college camps is that many college
professors
and i wrote this in my very first book
brainwashed when i was like 19. so it's
been a long time
it's been true for a very long time many
people on college campus because they
have a bubble of their own
never know that there is another point
of view out there about the world they
just don't understand that that point of
view exists
about the world and so they actually
think that their opinions are fact
and therefore their opinions are
universal
anybody who challenges that opinion is
an outlier their opinions are the
universal truth about the world
and this is how you end up with the
absurdity of james gunn
the again he's a disney director james
gun right he works for marvel
disney originally fired gun when a bunch
of his bad old tweets came out
these jokes about having sex with
children and stuff there were obvious
jokes they were like 2009 2010
and he ended up being fired from
guardians of the galaxy there were those
of us
like me i defended james gunn i said he
should not be canceled for bad old
tweets because we don't want to live in
a society where people are cancelled for
bad old joke tweets to mistake
so i stood up for james gunn because
even though i disagreed with the tweets
and i think they were dumb
and i think the jokes weren't funny and
i think that james gunn is wrong about
politics
i don't want to live in a society where
everybody gets cancelled for violating
the woke strictures of the day
james gunn however is a believer in the
will structures of the day he just
doesn't want to be canceled
so james gunn put out a thread regarding
all of this the other day he said stop
calling everything cancel culture
because you're too dim to have a nuanced
opinion
people can be offended by something or
think some something sucks and that's
not cancelled culture it's free speech
that's true cancer culture is where you
get somebody thrown out of their job to
all those writing me about the times
people get unfairly attacked yes that
sucks but that doesn't mean every time
someone is offended by something it's
cancelled culture
calling everything that is a knee-jerk
response that destroys your point
okay so far i don't disagree with this
but here is where it gets fun
he says pepe le pew is offensive because
of the way he treats that cat
but speedy gonzalez is not offensive and
so he shouldn't be cancelled
okay this is completely subjective now
so basically what james gunn is saying
is that if you remove pepe le pew from
tv that he has not been canceled because
he deserves to be canceled
but you should leave speedy gonzales
because james gunn for some reason love
speedy gonzales
don't worry guys it's not cancelled
culture so long as they're only
cancelling the stuff
that i want cancelled as long as they're
just canceling the stuff i want canceled
then it's not cancelled culture
at all okay this sort of mentality has
infused everything it has infused our
schools it has infused our colleges it
has infused our media
it has infused hollywood as if it has
infused our corporate life
this view is now crammed down by the
western royalty the wokes
they are the royalty because in the
intersectional hierarchy they sit right
there at the very top at the top of that
privileged hierarchy of people whose
opinions matter
great piece by barry weiss today over at
sub stack
about how this has infused america's
elite institutions
she writes the dissidents use pseudonyms
and turn off their videos when they meet
for clandestine zoom calls
they're usually coordinating soccer
practices and carpools now they come
together to strategize
they say they could face profound
repercussions if anyone knew they were
talking but the situation of light has
become too egregious for emails or
complaining on conference calls
so one recent weekend on a leafy street
in west la they gathered in person and
invited me to join
in the backyard behind a four bedroom
home ten people sat in a circle of
plastic adirondack chairs eating bags of
skinny pop
these are the rebels well-off la parents
who send their kids to harvard west like
the most prestigious private school in
the city and by the way harvard west
lake is prestigious it is a
boatload of money it's like 50 grand a
year for your kids to go to harvard west
lake
by normal american standards they are
quite wealthy by the standards of
harvard west like they are average
these are two career couples who credit
their own success not to family or
inherited wealth but to their own
education
so it strikes them as something more
than ironic that a school that costs
more than 40 grand a year
a school with charlie munger warren's
right hand and sarah murdock wife of
lachlan and rupert's daughter-in-law on
its board
is teaching students that capitalism is
evil for most parents the demonization
of capitalism is the least of it
they say their children tell them
they're afraid to speak up in class most
of all they worry the school's new plan
to become a quote unquote anti-racist
institution unveiled july in a 20-page
document
is making their kids fixate on race and
attach importance to it in ways that
strike them
as grotesque they are making my son feel
like a racist because of the
pigmentation of his skin
says one mother another poses a question
to the group how does focusing a
spotlight on race
fix how kids talk to one another why
can't they all just be wolverines
well harvard west lake has declined to
comment this
this harvard west like parents group is
one of them of many organizing quietly
around the country to fight what it
describes
as an ideological movement that has
taken over their schools
this story is based on interviews with
more than two dozen of these dissenters
at elite prep schools in two of the
bluest states in the country new york
and california
the parents in the backyard say that for
every one of them there are many more to
afraid to speak up
they're all eager for their story to be
told not a single one would let me use
their name
they worry about losing their jobs or
hurting their kids if they're opposition
to this ideology were known
the school can ask you to leave for any
reason said one mother at brentwood
another la prep school
then you'll be blacklisted from all the
private schools and you'll be known as a
racist which is worse than being called
a murderer
one private school parent born in a
communist nation says i came to this
country escaping the very same fear of
retaliation my own child now feels
another jokes we need to feed our
families oh and pay 50 grand a year to
have our children to get indoctrinated
a teacher in new york put it more
concisely to speak up against this is to
put all of your moral capital
at risk parents who have spoken out
against this ideology even in private
ways say it hasn't gone over well
i had a conversation with a friend i
asked him is there anything about this
movement we should question
said a father with children and two prep
schools in manhattan and he said dude
that's dangerous ground you're on
in our friendship i've had enough of
these conversations to know
what happens the atmosphere is making
their children anxious paranoid and
insecure
and closed off from even their close
friends my son knew i was talking to you
he begged me not to it's another harvard
west lake mother
he wants us to go to a great university
he told me one bad statement from me
will ruin
us this is the usa are you freaking
kidding me but this is the reality
this is the reality okay the the power
in america as barry weiss says now comes
from speaking woke a highly complex and
ever-evolving language this is a point
that i've made repeatedly and that i'm
going to make in my upcoming book
which is that woke-ism is about speaking
the lingo it is not about making the
world a better place it is an entry card
to the new ruling class that is what
woke-ism is
a harvard west lake english teacher
welcomes students back after summer with
i am a queer white womax
of european descent i use she her
pronouns but also feel comfortable using
they them pronouns
she attached a self-care letter quoting
audre lorde caring for myself is not
self-indulgence it is self-preservation
and that is an act
of political warfare wobatide the
working-class kid who arrives in
colleges and uses
and uses latino instead of latinx or who
stumbles conjugating verbs because a
classmate prefers to use the pronouns
that they them
yep this is the world in which we now
live the woke rule it is in fact a cult
it is a cult and that cult is in control
of the major institutions in american
society all righty in a little bit we'll
have another
hour of the ben shapiro show in the
meantime go check out the michael moore
show on today's episode
michael will be talking about the ever
worsening cuomo scandal that episode is
available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
the white house stonewalls reporters on
the record number of illegal alien kids
being held in cages
right-wing provocateur milo yiannopoulos
is now
ex-gay and the cuomo scandals get even
worse check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]